joining us now from here in Washington
is Hogan Gidley he's the White House
deputy press secretary for President
Trump it's great to see you how are you
thanks for coming on thank you so much
for having me that's the time oh I won't
quiz you on trade but I am gonna get
into what's happening on the fact that
we have the shutdown is over right but
now it's on to this February 8th
deadline not for passing some kind of
daca now Lindsey Graham Jeff Flake and
Dick Durbin the three of them they want
a plan that they tried to foist on the
president that a senior House member
tonight very senior told me would never
even be brought up for a vote Hogan
right it would never be brought up was
what I'm hearing as well and if it ever
got to the President's desk it would
never be signed the president was very
clear we all got to see the 55 minute
show with the bipartisan bicameral
meeting in the Cabinet Room coming out
of that the president said for my
national security package I need four
things that is border security with a
wall ending chain migration ending the
visa lottery and a lasting solution for
daca well luis Gutierrez over the
weekend said we gave him the money for
his stinking wall that he had the money
he didn't really care about yeah he
cares about the wall but we gave him
that what is the real truth about that
not true in fact the gram Durbin bill
didn't cover any of the things the
president outlined that he wanted in
fact it made the situation much worse it
increased illegal immigration it granted
amnesty to upwards of 8 million people
it did not fund the wall and it kept
chain migration going and real quickly
the migration policy institute says we
have about three point two five million
people here that are dreamers and daca
recipients that would have received
amnesty Graham and Durbin also in the
bill wanted their parents to receive
three years in the country and then once
they were all here they gave them the
right for chain migration as well so
you're talking about 8 million 10
million people by the time it's all said
and done it was absolutely incredible
now President Trump won in about three
different states with Wisconsin Ohio and
Pennsylvania that's right but about
80,000 votes gave them the election sure
now you're talking millions of new
voting American citizens many of them
probably beholden to the Democrats what
does that mean for the Republican Party
look you'll remember what when Ronald
Reagan actually did give amnesty I don't
think he got the thirty percent of any
of the folks that came here through the
amnesty package then the president is
completely opposed to this package
Graham and Durbin both were negotiating
with wake and flake as well they brought
it to the president they promised him it
did everything he wanted and the border
piece the wall pieces just talked about
DHS did a study and said we need not 1
but we need 18 billion dollars for the
wall this was less than 1/10 of that
they were talking about 1.6 billion
dollars for the wall it didn't fund a
thing Graham and Durbin know it and now
the lids been blown off and everyone
sees them for what they are I want to
play a sound bite for you and we're
gonna get back to Lindsey Graham because
he's driving the bus on this absolutely
and I what I want to talk more about
that but they're blaming Stephen Miller
that's their new target it was you know
Bannon and it go through the list now
it's Stephen Miller let's watch Stephen
Miller is the reason that the president
backed away from that immigration
decision they're not going to get there
by this path of allowing essentially
Stephen Miller and Tom cotton to be you
know in charge of all the policy in the
United States the reason we yanked these
things back is because mr. Miller his
view of immigration has never been in
the mainstream the Senate Trump rocks
the baseball cap Lindsay doesn't work
sorry this doesn't work for him god
bless them alright so now what Stephen
Miller is the big boogeyman I mean
shifting the shifting that the Stephen
Miller running policy running all the
immigration policy the president just
doesn't know what's going on that's the
other thing they're saying right they're
trying to have it both ways and Lindsey
Graham has said this repeatedly about
Miller about cotton about Purdue he's
attacking all of them and in a few
minutes I'm going to explain why they're
attacking me too but go ahead no
question and look I know Stephen Miller
very well I've worked with him now for
the three months I've been in the White
House and we spend a lot of time
together Stephen Miller serves at the
pleasure of the President as do I what
Stephen Miller was hired to do was
execute what the president wants done
this is the president's plan it's not
Stephen Miller's plan and Lindsey Graham
knows that there's no real
and for him to call out out in fact
there's no daylight between Donald Trump
and Stephen Miller on immigration
neither is there any daylight between
dick Durbin and Lindsey Graham unopened
why does Lindsey go on television and
claim there's a bipartisan deal that the
president rejected when it's Graham and
flake Graham and flake and then you
throw in Susan Collins again I'm sure
they're all really nice people they do
not track the president's views on
immigration you saw that poll that
Harvard Harris Paul Hogan shows that the
American people want immigration levels
even legal immigration levels reduced
the president is squarely in the
mainstream Lindsey Graham is a radical
fanatic on amnesty he has been for more
than ten years frankly I mean I'm great
harsh here a quick anecdote he is on the
fringe on this you the polls show it but
look I was in South Carolina I'm from
there he was my senator I was executive
director of the South Carolina
Republican Party at our state convention
2000 Republicans booing Lindsey Graham
for his stance on immigration because he
wants open borders and amnesty
he always has and it's his right to have
that position but don't pretend as
though you had to have a meeting of the
minds with dick Durbin and you gave up
something to get something
you guys dick Durbin and Lindsey Graham
and Jeff Flake have been on the same
page on this policy for decades
Hogan thank you so much for coming up
solutely thank you too in the trade quiz
is coming later